And to make the map more aesthetically pleasing,
as well as slightly more readable, you can change the color to be more striking.
In this case, setting the fill to be Udacity's orange, and
adding opacity so that we can see any overlapping circles.
Your last change, is to simply make the stroke of the circles black.
And to make it slightly thinner.
Going back to our map, you can see now that the circles with some opacity,
we can see countries in which the World Cup was held multiple times in,
which might be overlapping.
And while for our data set, the smaller circle always looks like it's on top.
There might arise the issue of larger circles getting on,
drawn on top of smaller circles, even with our opacity.
So again, while for our specific data set,
there doesn't look to be any of these larger circles drawn on top of
smaller circles hiding them, mostly for the reason we saw in our earlier plots.
Simply, later World Cups had more attendance than earlier World Cups.
In the interest of making our map more robust,
we want to make sure this will never happen, if we add new data.